immer mehr immer schneller immer höhere
gewinne chaplins bild vom kapitalismus
ist gültig bis heute
doch es gibt einen gegentrend es darf
auch weniger sein
mit dem houdini hat zürich ein neues
kino das eher klein aber fein ist ein
treffpunkt für filmliebhaber und
liebhaber der beinfreiheit so klein dass
auch besondere filme die fünf säle
füllen könne er ein mini plex als ein
multiplex benannt nach dem schauspieler
und magier harry houdini einem meister
des befreiungsschlags und das heißt also
ließ ich sind sondern sie sind und wie
wenig ein wenig platz aber hoch komfort
zum sitzen da hoch sich komfort das
engagement für den besonderen film war
ausschlaggebend dafür dass die
alternative bank schweiz einen
förderkredit vergab die bank weg einen
systemwechsel
wohl aber eine alternative zum
turbokapitalismus kleine projekte mit
sozialem ökologischem oder kulturellem
engagement position also machen sondern
im studio die große mehrzahl auch die
anspruchsvollen bedürfnisse abdeckt
die aktionäre der ubs verzichten ebenso
auf rendite wie die aktionäre der
routine betreiber von social capital und
auch die diskussion ist noch nicht so
weit fortschritte sie und dabei ist sich
eigentlich fast wie die einzig bank sie
wohl ohne ideen oka hat unser gauck für
die eine kulturelle nachhaltigkeit
projekt das hand- oder umweltschutz und
soziale projekte
die idee dazu stammt ausgerechnet aus
bangladesch einem der ärmsten länder der
welt
hier half die grameen bank mit
sogenannten mikrokrediten bauern und
kleinstunternehmen und verzichtete auf
sicherheiten zu gunsten des
gesellschaftlichen fortschritts
2006 erhielt mohammed yunus dafür den
friedensnobelpreis
in den industrienationen sollten die
unternehmen selbst soziales engagement
zeigen forderte yunus
in diesem sinne fließen förderkredite in
eine schweizer firma die biobaumwolle
verarbeitet in einsamen handlung die
alte kulturpflanzen sammelt und dadurch
die sortenvielfalt bewahrt in ein
kleines wasserkraftwerk im männerteam
kurhaus bergün noch so ein förderprojekt
aber was hat das mit der idee von
mohammed yunus zu tun
gemeinsame ist der zugang zum
kapitalmarkt staffel project wo
gesellschaftliche relevanz in
bangladesch ist natürlich soziale aspekt
extrem vordergrund selbständigkeit
schaffen
in der schweiz geht es um größere betrag
das ist klar aber das grundthema zugang
zum kapitalmarkt für noch nicht
etablierte projekt für initiative
zukunft geld verdienen
in der schweiz ist das oft eine
investition in den erhalt kultureller
vielfalt wie im kurs bei den heute
finden wir hier einen in der schweiz
fast einzigartigen jugendstil
und das ist ein paar enthusiasten zu
verdanken die mit viel liebe so etwas
geld von der abs die ramponierte
schönheit sanft saniert haben wohl zum
jahrhundert werden die jungen ist
natürlich der große hotelpool situation
entsprechen
hunde die vorsichtige rolle wollte kein
auge im jugendstil
bild reuters mit nun gut die handvoll
von gut erhaltener jugendstil und nutzte
die schweiz manche zimmer wirken als
wäre die zeit stehen geblieben
einfach mit lavabo das bad auf der etage
originalgetreu mit viel liebe zum detail
renoviert aber viel kleiner als heute
üblich ehemalige suiten mit eigenem bad
sind heute ferienwohnungen die sich auch
familien mit durchschnittlichem
einkommen noch leisten können
vor 100 jahren stand das kurhaus noch am
rand des dorfes
heute versteht es sich als teil von
bergen auch im kulturellen sinne
mit dem kinder kultur aus operieren
durchaus grund warum es mit süßer und
mit steuerpflichtig der knüppel berlin
das müsse aktiv daran beteiligen das
heißt mir ein verschiedenen konzert für
digital bevor für die klassiker ob es
stattfindet so ist hier eine neue zeit
angebrochen
mit engagement für die kultur und das
architektonische erbe eine neue zeit
ohne das immer schneller immer mehr
aber auch ohne die folgen welche die
jagd nach dem maximal gewinnen so mit
sich bringt